well this is this is sad guys this is
really pathetic I have to have to say my
wife and kids are out of town for the
week I've been I've been here at the
house by myself since Monday morning
because my wife wanted to go visit her
sister and and I have to work plus I got
a I'm going to Texas tomorrow for a
speech so that's how I ended up here
alone and so I got the whole house to
myself I've got I've got the run of the
house you know no wife no kids it's the
first time since I've been married that
that this has been the case I mean I
travel a lot so I'm on my own when I
travel most of the time but as far as
being home alone having the run of the
house no kids no wife first time and I
thought well I'm gonna really take
advantage of that I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna and I don't know I just I feel
like I should do something with this
freedom but the only thing I could the
only ways that I could find to take
advantage of it have been to eat a lot
of takeout food and leave wet towels on
the bathroom floor and that's that's it
that's what my celebration of
independence has consisted of and this
is adulthood I guess this is this is a
this is all it is what else well you
know what else am I really gonna do I
guess and then okay I did do one other
thing i sat on i sat on our white couch
last night and ate pizza so I did it and
I could never get away with that under
normal circumstances so I guess I did
have that one adventure that I will
remember and cherish always all right I
want to start with with with this story
you know there was in The Daily wire
trending now getting a lot of attention
very very interesting story there's a
kind of a lot going on here so let me
read now from Amanda's report in The
Daily wire it says a twenty-year-old
college student in upstate New York
reported an uber driver for refusing to
take her to get an abortion according to
the woman's account which was reported
on reported by Yahoo the ride-sharing
company canned the pro-lifer but now the
woman is looking to take legal action
against the driver she wrote in a on
reddit I'm in college in upstate New
York I don't have a car on campus
because it's expensive
20 years old I found out I was pregnant
and subsequently decided that I wanted
an abortion because I'm in no position
to take care of the child and she went
on to talk about she found a clinic
about an hour from the University and
then she had the call call an uber to
pick her up the student then going back
to the article says a student then
recounted her interaction with the uber
driver who attempted to dissuade the
woman from choosing abortion before
telling her he could not drive her to
the clinic she says quote my appointment
was at 11:30 a.m. so at 9:58 a.m. my
uber arrived and he immediately seemed
uncomfortable after about five minutes
in the car he asked are we going to a
Planned Parenthood I said no because we
weren't but it set off alarm by alarm
bells that he would even asked that she
continues the destination I put in was
just the name of the doctor and the
address of the clinic there was nothing
that would suggest it was an abortion
clinic after a few more minutes he asked
are we going to an abortion clinic I was
shocked she said I had no idea what to
say so I just remained quiet he then
said I know it's none of my business but
and proceeded to mention something about
his wife being pregnant how awful the
procedure was the abortion procedure
said that there's so much they don't
tell you and then said you're going to
regret this decision for the rest of
your life and she said that I was making
a mistake and then he about halfway to
the clinic he pulled over with no
warning he said I'm sorry but I can't
take you the rest of the way I can take
you back to the city but you won't be
able to find another uber out here so
then the woman said she finally got a
hold of her boyfriend who advised her to
call the clinic and inform them that
she'd be late talked to his boyfriend
some more
he came picked her up he managed to calm
her down and then she eventually did get
to the clinic and the abortion happened
but the driver driver was fired and now
she's looking at pursuing further legal
action against the driver saying that
you know she thinks she might have a
case she's reached out to a law firm
okay all right so a few points here
number one let's just pause for a moment
this is sort of a side issue but I
couldn't help but notice the cowardice
of the boyfriend in this situation his
girlfriend is going off presumably to
kill the child I mean we know he's just
killing child
presumably to kill his child presumably
apparently with his blessing but
originally he's not taking her he's
having an uber come and drive her an
hour to this clinic for the procedure to
be performed it says that she's you know
she was finally able to get a hold of
him and his advice is oh you know let
him know you'll be late and then finally
when she's stranded on the side of the
road he decides to come and pick her up
and take her the rest of the way
so it would appear that the boyfriend is
a deadbeat loser and that's the thing
about abortion that feminists ignore
because they have to ignore it or they
feel like they have to is that abortion
is great for deadbeat losers like this
boyfriend this idea that you know men
are opposed to abortion or that the
pro-life movement is a man's movement
Manou it's like it like it's it's only
men who are opposed to abortion the
pro-life movement is just about is just
men because it's some sort of sexist
conspiracy well that is just obviously
absurd because the fact is lots of men
like this woman's boyfriend love
abortion and they hate pro-lifers
because abortion enables them to use
women for sexual pleasure with with the
assurance that the consequences of their
rendezvous will be disposed of and
disposed of we should note on the
woman's dying most of the time on her
conscience and she will be the one to
suffer most of the physical and
emotional pain from it now men can also
and often do suffer incredible emotional
pain from abortion if they are willing
to confront what it is that's happening
but oftentimes men at least men who are
who go along with this and encourage
their their girlfriends and to get
abortions they're not confronting it and
they're not forced to because they don't
even have to go to the clinic they could
just sit back and say oh yeah you know
it's getting abortion take care take
care of it right
so for scummy men for looser men for
selfish men abortion is great they
absolutely love it
men men gain nothing from opposing
abortion
you know I've opposed abortion all my
life I have not benefited practically
from this position how could I nobody on
this side does man or woman we take this
position purely for ethical reasons
that's the only reason we take it
there's nothing else we stand to gain
this whole idea about you know men want
to control women's bodies and so forth
that also is obviously ridiculous and I
don't deny that some men in the world do
want to control women's bodies you can
look at the Middle East for instance
women have to walk around in body bags
essentially and often that you know they
can't vote they can't drive they they
don't have any any self-determination
whatsoever so okay yes now there is an
example when you've got Sharia law
you've got a patriarchal society where
men have claimed the right and the power
the authority to control women's bodies
that really does happen and it's
happening in those kinds of societies
but a man who says look women can wear
what they want they can say what they
want they can live how they want they
can do what they want within the law
women can have all the same
opportunities as men women are legally
equal legally equal to men in every way
a man who says that is not a man who is
looking to control women's bodies and if
that man happens to be pro-life that is
only because he believes that the body
in question here the body under dispute
is not the woman's body but the child's
body and that is a separate body and as
for that body he does not think that it
should be destroyed you can disagree
now you're wrong and foolish to disagree
but you can but to call that controlling
women's bodies is idiotic
and to accuse that man of wanting to
control women's bodies is idiotic if he
wanted to control women he'd be a
supporter of Sharia law and if you
wanted to exploit women and use them
he'd be pro-abortion but being not a
supporter of Sharia law yet pro-life
well that is just that is a that is
simply an ethical position that has
nothing to do with controlling anyone
all right so that's kind of a side issue
that I ranted about but I think it's I
think it's an important point when you
see the role of the man in these kinds
of stories on this particular topic
though I think there are a few things a
few other things that jump out first the
driver the uber driver acted heroically
he found himself in a moral quandary
that that he probably never anticipated
he would be in so he somehow knew how
it's not clear from the story how did he
know that she was going to an abortion
clinic he somehow knew it maybe it maybe
came up on the GPS he recognized the
name whatever and he realized where he
was going and what he was unwittingly
taking part in and so he had two choices
at that point he could just go along
with it he could say nothing he could
protect his livelihood and his
reputation and his convenience and and
do the convenient easy thing take her
take the money be done with it or he
could refuse to take part he could you
could try to talk to the woman he could
try to reason with her and ultimately if
that fails he could refuse to go along
with it and say I can't take you there
now I think many many many people even
pro-life people would probably choose
the first option the path of least
resistance
and they would say you know it's got
it's got nothing to do with me it's not
my fault I'm just gonna take her it's
not worth the trouble
he chose the second route and that is
heroism that is real heroism and he
deserves credit for that especially in a
culture where we there's there's so
little moral heroism yet heroism is so
often claimed yeah there's a there's a
vast disparity between the the the
number of times that the word hero
is used to describe something and the
number of times that we actually see
real heroics so I just saw a story about
a woman maybe you saw this online a
woman who threw a bag of puppies into a
dumpster in California and she's since
been arrested and for good reason
but she throws the bag of puppies in a
homeless guy comes by and he's you know
he's looking through the dumpster for
whatever he can salvage he happens to
find the puppies and he pulls them out
and he finds someone and and the the
puppies are safe now the homeless guys
being called a hero that's what the
media is calling him a hero well I'm
glad he pulled the puppies out don't get
me wrong
it's it's a good thing that he did I'm
not certainly not criticizing him
obviously but that's not heroic it's a
good thing to do but it's not heroic any
decent human being would do the same
right it's the instinctive response
anyone if you saw a bag of puppies in a
dumpster you would take the bag out to
not take it out would be unbelievably
evil you would be just as evil as the
woman who who threw the bag in so what
we're saying about this homeless man is
what we're saying is he's not
unbelievably evil which is great but
just because you're not unbelievably
evil doesn't make you a hero and just
reaching in and grabbing the bag and
said well okay and bringing it so it's
not heroic and I do think it's an
important point again I'm not get snot a
criticism it's just let's let's calm
down from and stop calling everything
heroic because when you do that you
cheapen heroism heroism is when you risk
something it's when there are two
options and one is the easier less risky
more advantageous route for you
but you reject that path and take the
riskier less advantageous harder path
because it's the ethically superior path
now that is what heroism is that's what
a hero does and I want to be clear about
that now does so that's a rope does uber
have the right to fire this guy well
they
do absolutely I wish they didn't I don't
think they should have but it's their
company they have the right to do that
they don't have to keep him employed if
they don't agree with his decision they
they can decide to fire him they can
hire and fire whoever they want I
believe that I believe in in the rights
of employers to make these kinds of
decisions you know absolutely and other
drivers who work for uber will just have
to decide if they want to remain
affiliated with the company and we as
potential passengers will have to decide
if we want to give our money to the
company that's that's a decision we'll
have to make but uber has that right
that's a separate question though from
does the woman have a case against the
driver can she sue him and I would say
no well she could file the lawsuit but
does she have a case no because what
were her case be the fact is she's
sitting in this man's car he owns the
car he might drive for uber but that
doesn't make him her slave and if he
doesn't want to take her to a certain
place he has the right the legal right
and the moral right as well to say no to
make that decision it would be a similar
thing TIFF and I know there are over
drivers and cab drivers in this
situation where you've got someone who
gets in your car is plastered drunk and
says hey take me to the bar take me to
the liquor store and so you not only
have the right but I would say probably
moral obligation in that case to say no
I'm not going to take you because it's
not right you're not in a position to go
drink right now so it's the same sort of
situation this this guy was not under
any legal obligation to go take her to
kill her child and it's as simple as
that now of course yeah what does it
tell you about this woman that she not
only did what she did to her child but
now she's not satisfied with getting
this guy fired now she wants to sue him
as well and what does it really tell you
well I'll tell you what I'll tell you
what it tells you it tells us that I'm
other things this is a woman with a with
a seared conscience this is a woman with
a guilty conscience and I think
sometimes people on the pro-life side
can miss that when you see women who are
vindictive in their support for abortion
and who looked to punish anyone who
opposes it and a woman like this who she
already got his got him fired
tako took his livelihood away you'd
think that'd be enough now she wants to
go further well that's just this she is
someone who's trying to convince herself
that she's the victim and that she's in
the right and she's the good guy she's
trying to convince herself and so many
of the arguments for abortion that you
hear especially from radical feminists
and from as I said the most vindictive
types when you hear the arguments one of
the reasons why the arguments they
present are so bad and unconvincing and
illogical and irrational is that they're
not really presenting the argument to
you they're not really talking to you
they're talking to themself to
themselves there they are
they're trying to convince themselves of
what they're saying it's not about
convincing you but committing themselves
because at some level they know that
this is wrong and any woman who's gotten
an abortion at some level knows that
what she did was wrong and there are
many women who at every level know that
it's wrong and regret it and and and
unfortunately live with with guilt and
and you know emotional hardship that
they will struggle with probably their
whole lives and and which of course the
the clinics and Planned Parenthood will
just leave them with because Planned
Parenthood isn't going to offer any post
abortive counseling to women who are
struggling with this because Planned
Parenthood would deny that that that
that's even that even happens so but
that's just that's an important point
here about this this will be an
interesting case to continue to follow
right let's so in order to mention this
as well you know Charlize Theron Theron
however you pronounce your last name I
never have been quite sure to be honest
she recently complained that she is
quote shockingly single at the age of 43
and I guess there were some people who
were confused by that well how could how
could this woman a very attractive woman
Hollywood celebrity rich how could she
be single how has she not found a man by
now well I think now we know why because
in another interview that was published
last week late last week she quote
confirmed that her seven-year-old son is
actually a girl the poor young boy who
she now parades around in a dress
announced his gender identity at the age
of three
according to Charlize Theron he
announced his gender identity and this
is this is the quote from Theron she
says yes I thought she was a boy too
until she looked at me and when she was
three years old and said I am NOT a boy
and that's how at the age of three at
the age of three that's how she
discovered that her son is really a girl
now I I have a son who is almost three
and I have twins who passed that
threshold a couple of years ago I can
say from experience that a child at the
age of three knows nothing about the
world just knows absolutely nothing he
cannot speak in complex sentences he
thinks cartoons are real okay when a
three-year-old watches TV he thinks that
the cartoons are real creatures who are
literally inside the TV talking to him
okay that's what he thinks
he doesn't know the difference between
truth and fiction literally doesn't know
the difference as in if you were to say
to a three-year-old or even a
four-year-old unicorns aren't real well
you're not you're not spoiling
because they don't even they don't
understand what that means they don't
know what not-real means that doesn't
mean anything to them that sentence so
they don't understand the difference
between truth and fiction they you know
a three-year-old believes in Santa and
unicorns and monsters under his bed he
thinks that his toys come to life when
he leaves the room he is slightly more
intelligent than a goat basically and
slightly less intelligent than a dolphin
no offense the three-year-olds i you
know i think i think three-year-olds are
awesome too by the way i think it's a
great age it's one of my favorite maybe
maybe my my favorite age for a little
kid but the point is that these are
these are very these are not very
intellectually developed or complex
beings yet at that stage these are
people who believe literally anything
they're told on any subject when my
twins were that age for instance and you
know I I admit that I'd like to do this
with my kids I'll just tell them the
craziest stories I can think of and so I
I told my I told my kids and they were
three my twins that I used to live on
the moon when I was a kid and I had a
pet flying shark named rocky and I flew
down here from the moon on my shark okay
and I told them that they were so
thrilled by that biographical detail
about my life that I didn't have the
heart to admit I was lying and they
might still actually believe it for all
I know they might be telling their
friends that their that their daddy used
to live on the moon riding up a flying
shark so what I'm trying to stress here
is just that three-year-old children are
very very young and they are very very
limited there in their ability to
understand anything and one subject that
they certainly cannot grasp is biology
so the next time you hear a
three-year-old boy claim to be a girl
which is an extraordinarily common
phenomenon okay
it is this it's a very common for for
young boys to say stuff like that it's
only recently that the adults have
become so stupid and diluted that they
they hear that I think oh my gosh this
is so significant this he just claimed
to be occur
for thousands of years three-year-olds
would say stuff like that and the
parents would go okay honey all right
pat him on the head send them on their
way but if you really are concerned or
if you're confused well here's something
the next time you hear a three-year-old
child three-year-old boy claim to be a
girl here's the follow up question to
ask this this child say okay what's a
girl now if that statement means
anything coming from his mouth then he
should be able to answer that question
and tell you what he thinks a girl is
but he won't be able to answer that
question because the word girl to him
means nothing
it is a sound that people make when he
says I'm a girl he may as well be saying
I'm Ahuja what's it or I'm an apple or
you know I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
couch I mean it just it's just it's a
these are just words they don't mean
anything to him at the absolute most at
the absolute most if this is a a child
who is very developed in his thinking
and is much smarter than your average
three-year-old then maybe when he says
that what he might mean is that he is
interested in the things that his little
toddler brain associates with girls like
bright colors Princesses fairies dolls
etc it probably doesn't even mean that
because most three-year-olds can't draw
those associations like that but at most
at most that's what it means at most you
could translate I'm a girl too I think
Tinkerbell is cool and considering he
thinks that Tinkerbell is real I can
hardly blame him for thinking that I
mean me I think it'd be cool too if
ticker bell was real so you know of
course this whole conversation is
unnecessary in general because our sex
is not something that we can reject or
change at any age so it doesn't
three-year-olds can't decide their
gender neither can 33 year olds nobody
can it's just as scientifically
impossible but even if I hit my head and
I woke up believing that biology really
is adjustable and you can change it
I would need to suffer several more
traumatic brain injuries before I would
get to the point where I would think
that toddlers could be entrusted to make
those adjustments even a person confused
enough to believe in the whole concept
of transgenderism should still be sane
enough to understand that a human being
who's only three or four years old
cannot possibly be entrusted with that
decision
that's methought I want to stress is the
levels of crazy that we're dealing with
here
where you've got the whole idea that you
can change your sex that's crazy enough
and now but but even if I were to accept
that premise which of course I do not
even a little bit accept it but even if
I did I I would still there's no way
that I would think that a three-year-old
could be could could do that there are a
lot of actual decisions that we can make
with our lives as adults but that we
don't let children make in fact
three-year-olds we don't really let
three-year-olds make any decisions
really every just every decision they
make is in a very controlled environment
and we exercise the right to override it
and we do override almost all of their
independent decisions I mean I mean if
you've got a three-year-old especially a
three-year-old boy you're sitting there
all day so you're trying to stop them
from killing themselves honestly I don't
know how any three-year-old boy survives
past past three I'm considering how
often you have to step in and avert
disaster for them so I mean have you
ever have you ever been you know you go
to a cold stone or some you know someone
who's ice cream places and have you ever
been stuck in line behind a mother and a
child
a young child where the mother for
whatever reason is letting the child
decide every all the detail what kind of
ice cream he wants and what he wants on
the ice cream well you're gonna be
you're gonna be sitting there for 72
hours because the child cannot make even
that decision if you put 32 flavors in
front of a child say which flavor do you
want
and here
topics which topics he cannot decide he
really can't so you have to just make
that now experience parents no I'm not
gonna give you a choice at most I'll
give you you know ice cream or vanilla
and you've got 30 second you've got 10
seconds to decide but probably I'll just
decide for you and whatever I decide
you'll like you don't need to decide for
yourself it's ice cream you'll enjoy so
kids at that age can't make any
decisions the idea that they could make
a decision like this is is insane now I
call it insane but there's a question
here Charlize Theron and and people like
her are they really that insane or are
they purposefully instilling gender
confusion into their perfectly healthy
and normal children simply to be
fashionable so is this wickedness on the
part of the parents or mental illness
and again I'm talking about the parents
now a three-year-old child is neither
wicked nor mentally ill just it's just
just that's a normal kid but it seems to
me to a parent to allow your
three-year-old to choose his gender you
would have to be mentally ill or evil I
I don't see any room in between I don't
see a third option here and that's
really the only question on this matter
okay I did want to briefly revisit the
topic of student loan forgiveness and I
guess this counts as a mailbag thing
because I'm gonna respond to some of the
feedback Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com is the email
address so for example this is along the
lines of a lot of other email I received
that says hello Matt I generally agree
with your takes but I think you're way
off base on the student loan issue if
you don't have any loan debt then you
don't understand the crushing effect it
has people's lives are being destroyed
our country would be greatly benefited
by a plan to get rid of this burden it
seems you have no empathy for people
struggling and that's disappointing you
usually strike me as a humble and
compassionate person despite how you're
portrayed but on this issue yesterday
and other times when you talk about it
you come across like a huge jerk very
disappointing
at least other at least offer solutions
instead of simply mocking people who are
struggling alright first of all I did
offer a solution as I explained
yesterday this crisis could be solved
rather easily and without any sweeping
governmental programs if we took a very
simple step there's a very simple step
we could take that wouldn't get this
problem in the long term and all that
needs to happen I will reiterate is this
we have to stop shipping every
eighteen-year-old
off to a four-year college right out of
high school that's my whole point and as
long as we are determined to continue
along this suicidal path nothing is
going to change but if we're interested
in restoring a little bit of sanity to
the proceedings we don't ultimately need
free college or loan forgiveness or any
other form of welfare because this would
solve the problem again long term now
this you're still gonna have to pay your
own loans that's something you're gonna
have to do but 20 30 years from now we
could make it so that this problem
doesn't exist anymore just by making
this one simple societal change it's a
change that there is no downside to it
there's no downside and there's a ton of
upside to a kid out of high school
getting a job for a few years saving
some money gaining experience gaining
maturity and figuring out what he
actually wants to do with his life
before deciding on his educational plan
I just I cannot think of any rational
argument against this course of action I
can think of trillions of arguments
against the course of action that we
commonly take of shipping every kid off
to college right from high school if we
turned off that conveyor belt this
conveyor belt that unthinkingly dumps
every high school graduate into a
four-year institution ultimately we
would end up with fewer people going to
college because a lot of people in the
interim would discover vocations that
don't require a college degree and the
ones who do attend will be more
financially secure they'll have more
money they'll have more maturity and
they'll have they'll have an idea more
of an idea probably as to what they
actually want to do with their life so
they can get a
more targeted education and they can
they can enter into a major that that
actually will be useful to them
so that's my solution and I think it's a
good solution if by solution you mean a
a switch that we could just flip and all
of this goes away well no I don't have
that and I don't think there is a
magical switch as for lacking sympathy
that's not true I have a ton of sympathy
for people who are in debt I have
sympathy for people who are underwater
with their mortgage or the credit card
debt or medical bills or student loans
or or any kind of debt I mean if you're
in debt to them to the Mafia I had a lot
of sympathy for you
whether it was recklessness or
happenstance or you know personal
tragedy or whatever it is that put you
in that position I have sympathy I have
compassion so I'll make that clear if I
hadn't already made it clear but the
moment that you demand that the
government can script your fellow
citizens to pay your debt for you the
moment you try to by using the mechanism
of the state appropriate money from
other people from your fellow human to
alleviate your own suffering that's the
moment that I lose all sympathy because
it's the moment that you become a thief
and that's how i thats how i see this if
you are asking now you might not be the
one going you might not be putting on a
ski mask and going in and robbing a
liquor store or something but you I mean
in some ways this is worse because it's
less honest at least at least a thief a
you know a thief in the a mask knows
what he's doing and admits it but when
you go to the government and say you
know I don't want to get my hands dirty
but what I want you to do is I want you
to go and take money from those people
over there and give it to me I I just
see that as theft I do and so no I don't
have any sympathy for that that's the
difference all the sympathy no sympathy
in the world for people who are who are
struggling when you try to alleviate
your own struggles and your own
suffering by causing it among other
people well sorry I mean the sympathy
meter just went from a hundred down to
zero as quickly as that that's that's
how I look at it this is from mica says
hey mister Walsh
aren't bees communists well I suppose
they are in a way no private property
everything owned by the state which
would be the queen bee so at well
actually I guess it's more of a it's
more of a serfdom it's kind of like a
feudal type of situation really the
greater concern for me is that bees are
radical feminists only the women work or
contribute the men are used for for
menial tasks around the hive and for
mating mostly and and then it wintertime
they're evicted into the snow or
murdered by the hive to save resources
so it's a very troubling anti-male
attitude in the bee community and it's
something that I'll be working on with
my own hive in fact I installed my hive
last night and I did give them a quick
lecture on gender equality it's just a
quick but forty five minutes and I'll be
going back later tonight to kind of get
around to and I plan to worry I'll go
every you know two or three times a week
and I'll have different time different
subjects as well but I just I think it's
very important to have well-educated
bees now actually speaking of which and
this is true I I went to pick up my bees
yesterday and I was picking them up from
an apiary which is basically a bee farm
and I get there's my firt I've never
picked up these before so I don't really
know what the process is and it's I pull
up and it's this older woman and her and
her husband and she goes alright well
we'll put on your bee suit and I said I
I didn't know I needed to bring my bee
suit to pick up the bees I thought that
I was just gonna be getting a box and I
would bring it home and I didn't realize
that picking up the bees meant going
down into the bee yard where hundreds of
thousands of bees are swarming around
like mad and I had to secure my own box
of bees which means putting in they give
you gave me this yellow cork and a
rubber band and she pointed to a palate
of a bunch of boxes of bee
with bees all swarming around she said
okay she choose one of those boxes and
you got to put the cork in cuz there's a
there's some entrance where the bees fly
in and out before the box is picked up
so you got a corked up the hole which is
swarming with bees and then put the the
rubber band that's gonna be the only
thing that keeps the bach box closed
while you're driving home and I had to
go do that without a bee suit and that
was a little bit nerve-racking the one
piece of advice the woman gave me she
said she said be quick and smart and I
said okay that was her advice so I
grabbed the bees and it was a little bit
anti-climatic honestly because I didn't
I didn't get any other advice besides be
quick and smart they didn't ask me any
questions so other than that they were
just basically like all right enjoy your
bees see you later
and I thought shouldn't they I mean
shouldn't they ask for my driver's
license or something how do they I feel
like there should be more going on here
I mean I I'm picking up a box of 10,000
angry bees then I drove home 20 or 30
miles very windy and hit hilly roll roll
you know why Indy and hilly roads with a
big box of bees sitting next to me to
hear him buzzing in the passenger seat
and I kept thinking to myself man there
there is just a rubber band separating
me from 10,000 bees what if I hit a deer
what if I what if I hit a deer and the
air bags come out and this box opens up
and then I'm killed and I'm stuck behind
the airbag that being stung to death and
then I started thinking myself what kind
of headline will that be you know
conservative commentator stung to death
by 10,000 bees after a fender bender
with deer and then I thought that would
be kind of a funny headline and I don't
know how I feel about having my death
become a funny headline on Drudge Report
or something anyway I made it home alive
and I got the bees in and and now I'm a
beekeeper folks so there's that story
all right um
from Dominic says hi Matt I'm a 17-year
old who is not going to college due to
your advice I've been listening to your
show for a few months now and I've been
persuaded not to attend college at least
for a few years after graduation
instead gonna start working full-time
after high school one thing I've noticed
is that there's an extreme amount of
pressure on kids to go to college people
come up to me and instead of asking my
plans after high school they ask what
college
you're going to when I say I'm not going
to attend college they always give me a
disappointed look however when I explain
to them my reasoning which I get from
you they always act as if they haven't
even thought about it before and
brighten up I think there is no way this
pressure is healthy and I applaud you
for standing against it
well Dominic I plugged you for making a
difference but I think wise decision
look ultimately you got to do what's
right for you so I'm not gonna sit here
and try to tell an individual person
personally what's right for them but I
think that look I don't I don't see
Dominic any downside in your plan you're
gonna go get a job you could still go to
college if you decide you want to it's
not a race you've got plenty of life
still ahead of you God willing so get a
job make some money have some experience
maybe when you're 20 years old you'll
decide hey I want to go to college and
then you can and you'll have you'll act
you can actually do that and have money
when you do it so I think that that's a
wonderful plan and I don't suspect that
you'll regret it I I don't think you
know I really doubt that there's anyone
at the age of 40 who waited three or
four years to go to college out of high
school and regrets it like they're
living in regret wishing they had gone
when they were 18 instead of 20 or 21 I
don't think there's anyone in that
position so you're pretty safe as far as
that goes this is from norm says oh
great theocratic fascist dictator the
wisest of all dude man Burroughs Walsh
the bearded how can I grow a great beard
such as the one of your own chin I fear
being executed when you gain power in
the foreseeable future for my lack of
beard growth please tell me so I may
save myself well norm I appreciate that
you are thinking about this and and your
intuition is correct that you will be
executed unfortunately and as I always
emphasize it's nothing personal you know
when I am carrying out these sentences
it is only because it's the law which
has been arbitrarily decided by my own
deranged winds as far as how do you do
it I you know
I guess there's not really any advice I
can offer it's just all I can say is
figure it out you know you've got a few
years until I complete my takeover of
the country and then the world so look I
don't know figure it out and and push
comes to shove you know you could look
at beard implants I don't know but
you're you're coming up against the
deadline that's all I can say let's see
from Cindy says Matt please stop using
the word miracle on your show your
pronunciation of that word causes me
great anxiety please stop I can't take
it anymore
I get like 10 emails like this every day
no people claiming the I say miracle and
I'm supposed to pronounce miracle Mira
is that what you want Cindy miracle
no it's miracle miracle it's a gosh darn
miracle that's how I'm gonna say from
now on that's what you just earned all
you people with your discriminatory
attitudes towards my Baltimore accent
will do one more if I can find one let's
see this from Allison says hi Matt Matt
I agree with a lot of your take on the
Democratic lineup for 2020 so not even
worth going through why none of them are
worth our votes agreed however I have
such mixed feelings about Trump as I
believe you do too
I see that his administration has done a
lot of good for the country at the same
time I don't like Trump leading us I
don't like the way he talks to and about
others he disagrees with I don't like
his narcissism the fact that he just
can't refrain from making comments that
do no good for his image and
unfortunately by extension the image of
Republicans these are of course just a
few examples I know this could or would
never happen but I can't help feeling
like can't Republicans just pick a new
candidate for 2020 someone to continue
most of the policies but who it could be
we could be proud of and generally feel
comfortable with why do we have to
automatically continue with Trump I
realize the threat that this would cause
a big division within the party is
probably why we can't really consider it
but how about what about how about Trump
has just offered a new reality TV deal
if he backs a different Republican
candidate interested to hear your
thoughts on what if anything could allow
us to consider a different kind
yeah Alice and I basically agree with
your assessments there including your
assessment that which you offered which
is you that this hypothetical you're
talking about could never happen will
never never happen won't happen it just
doesn't happen where a party kicks out
their incumbent or tries to so it's
simply not gonna happen I as I have
expressed and I know that Trump's most
devoted followers don't want to hear it
don't like hearing it but I think that
there is a significant chance that Trump
loses certain there's certainly a
significant chance he loses there's a
significant chance he loses in a
landslide and maybe for his own good and
now it's again it's not gonna happen but
you could argue that it would be in his
best interest to say hey I'm a one-term
president I'm stepping out I'm not
losing I just I chew I've done my I've
done what I wanted to do and I've
succeeded in this and so now I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna pass the torch to
someone else I think that would be a
politically savvy and smart move for
Trump and he could avoid the landslide
loss he would also give Republicans a
much better chance of winning in 2020 if
they don't have Trump to run against
anymore I mean they're their entire plan
is to run obviously he's running against
Trump and that's what they're you know
they're not really planning on putting
forward any vision for the future their
whole thing is gonna be anti Trump
anti-trump anti Trump and just getting
up as much of that Trump hatred as
possible which won't be difficult to do
because the reality is no matter how
anyone personally feels about the guy a
lot of people in this country hate his
guts now you might not think they should
but they do and there are a lot of
people in that camp and there are a lot
of people who believe that he's a racist
and a sexist at all these things I don't
think he is a racist I think that's
absurd that that claim I think there's
no basis for it whatsoever but he has
successfully been painted that way and
you could say well they do that with
every Republican true but they've done
it much more success
with Trump and in some cases he has made
it easy on them again not because he's
really racist but because he just has no
discipline whatsoever in what he says
and that is not an advantage it just
isn't the whole comment about you know
during the white supremacist rally in
Charlottesville he said they're good
people on both sides I mean that's one
of those comments that Minh 11 infamy
they're gonna throw that at him again
and again and again in 2020 they've been
throwing out it Adam for the last few
years to great effect
maybe not effective to Trump's fans but
to a lot of other people they hear the
comment like that I think what good
people on both sides so that kind of
thing is what they can use and the point
is in order for Trump to win he is going
to need depressed turnouts in places
like Philadelphia and Detroit which will
give him a chance to win Michigan and
Pennsylvania but that ain't gonna happen
it just isn't those voters are coming
out and they're coming out kids Trump
they're not coming out for him and so
that's that's gonna be the problem
anyway yeah it's it's he's going to be
the candidate and that's all there is to
it and we'll see we'll see what happens
but Alison I will tell you that I agree
with what you're saying here and you are
not alone there are a lot of Republicans
and conservatives who feel the same way
and they're also a lot who didn't feel
that way to begin with it there are a
lot of people who kind of liked Trump's
whole shtick but now have grown tired of
it and have grown tired of it especially
because although he has done some good
things and he has followed through on
some of his promises he also has done a
lot of nothing at the same time he spent
a lot of time tweeting a lot of time
arguing with cable news personalities a
lot of time worried about you know
exacting vengeance via Twitter on anyone
who insults him but not a lot of time
you know for instance trying to get the
wall built which he could have done
he had the he had the government you
know he had Republicans control the
government from for the first two years
of his presidency
you could try to blame Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell all you want the fact is
he could have had this fight right then
and there from day one he's gonna said
we're gonna get this wall built and he
could have obsessively focused on it and
if he had done that it would have
happened because he had leverage over
Republicans he has none over Democrats
he waited until Democrats controlled the
house to even try to build the wall
which tells me that he doesn't really
care about building it and and I think
there are a lot of voters who have
noticed that and are going to be less
excited about coming out in 2020 for
that reason all right I'll leave it on
that depressing note that's your fault
Ellison no I'm kidding thank you for the
email and thanks for watching everybody
Godspeed I'm Michael Knowles host of the
Michael Knowles show a woman is suing an
uber driver for refusing to take her to
an abortion meanwhile leftists weep over
a sack full of puppies in a dumpster we
will examine our clinical culture check
it out of Daily wire calm